[Music]
and let's talk about the rules right now
what you see in front of you three
plates of mint noodles yes I'm having
six total fingers up right now okay you
have to deal with that two plates are
simply delicious but one of these plates
is super spicy hot the likes of which
you've never experienced we're talking
world breaking hot all right here we go
round one remember the spice is going to
get progressively hotter with each round
spinning now do not forget the plate is
your feet in case you haven't noticed it
stops spinning so it's time to start
eating
[Music]
why is this happening to you why is this
happening to you it's because you
deserve it's because you deserve it's I
feel like I'm reading fire I'm genuinely
it's going to my door now ladies and
gentlemen what you see before you
pine up occurred keep in mind the spice
is increased for round two so stakes are
higher and of course don't forget that
the plate is your fate okay
who is it is it Marlon is it April is it
sky
[Music]
it's only a matter of seconds now we can
feel this guy
listen stop line it's already happens
you're in the pain during it ok ladies
and gentlemen we're in sudden death
thank you what's happening right now is
insane this plate right here is so
incredibly hot that you have never
tasted anything like it before
it is the hottest thing you have ever
tasted that haven't been set
normally this is where I would say the
plate is your fate but this is so hot it
is beyond catchphrases are you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go for it Marlon that's a great that's a
great big
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's that's really I think this would
be a good time to exchange deepest
darkest secrets
oh man it's coming on okay it's coming
on just think about this think about
this it's really I mean the ladies love
seeing this kind of stuff in a man to
see a man be able to withstand pain like
this it ladies love them don't take the
milk I'm go case guy I'm okay yes yes
I'm okay
[Music]
my [ __ ] it's gonna burn for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go yeah where were inside nose
hairs right now I'm just worried
we absolutely know we're gonna make you
a chili jam
[Music]